[Musica]
voglio mostrarvi un video
siamo in cina ci sono dei contadini
vanno al lavoro la mattina presto e fin
qua insomma tutto normale direte voi ma
guardate un po che cosa succede guardate
che cosa fanno
so cosa state pensando non è possibile
siamo nella provincia del sichuan in
cina appunto qui per colpa dell'uso
massiccio di pesticidi gli insetti
impollinatori sono scomparsi
ora questi contadini se vogliono
raccogliere delle pere da questi alberi
sono costretti a fare l'impollinazione a
mano l'ente intergovernativo dell'onu
per le politiche di biodiversità ha
calcolato che il valore economico
dell'impollinazione degli insetti a
livello mondiale si aggira intorno ai
500 77 miliardi di dollari all'anno
la 84 per cento di quello che viene
coltivato in europa ha bisogno
dell'impollinazione e il 70 per cento di
quello che finisce sulle nostre tavole
a livello mondiale è il frutto
dell'impollinazione degli insetti
va da sé che senza questo servizio tra
l'altro gratuito offerto dai dagli
insetti
insomma per noi sarebbe un bel problema
prendiamo per esempio la nostra
colazione potremo dire addio a caffè
succo di frutta spremuta marmellate e
ovviamente anche cappuccino e brioche
sì perché comunque anche i latticini
sono il frutto di animali che a loro
volta si nutrono di mangimi vegetali che
a loro volta sono il frutto
dell'impollinazione quindi niente più
carne frutta verdura insomma gli
scaffali del vostro supermercato
preferito potrebbero apparire così è in
gioco il futuro della nostra
alimentazione
alcuni ricercatori tedeschi hanno
raccolto per trent'anni in questi ultimi
trent'anni i campioni di insetti vivi
ebbene si sono accorti che sono
diminuiti dell 80 per cento siamo
entrati nella prima estinzione di massa
dopo i dinosauri insetti stanno
scomparendo otto volte più velocemente
di qualsiasi altro animale mammifero
rettile che conosciamo
nell'arco di cento anni molte specie
scompariranno dalla faccia della terra
molti chiamano questo fenomeno come la
sindrome del parabrezza
vi ricordate vedo comunque persone di
una certa età quando eravamo bambini o
eravate bambini o ragazzi facevamo delle
scampagnate fuori casa con i genitori
andavamo oppure al mare in montagna
vi ricordate la quantità di insetti
spiaccicati che rimanevano sul
parabrezza
ve lo ricordate provate a pensarci
adesso quando è stata l'ultima volta che
vi è successa non succede più
evidentemente c'è qualcosa che non va io
ho cominciato a fare apicoltura 15 anni
fa mi sono avvicinato a e api con grande
rispetto con grande curiosità vi
assicuro che è un'emozione incredibile è
veramente un contatto con la natura
unico aprire un alveare con 50 60 mila
esemplari ronzanti purtroppo però mi
sono reso conto che ultimamente questa
enfasi delle delle api da miele che
stanno scomparendo dio le api da miele
non ci saranno più sta un po sbattendo
in faccia la porta molti altri insetti
io oggi non voglio sputare nel piatto
dove ho mangiato ma voglio attirare la
vostra attenzione perché se vi dicessi
per esempio quante specie di pesci
conoscete o che ne so di uccelli o di
mammiferi sono sicuro che potremmo stare
qui a fare una lista infinita ma se vi
facesse la stessa domanda parlando di
api
quante specie di api conoscete certo
l'app che fa il miele e poi al mondo
esistono 20 mila specie di api diverse
in europa ce ne sono 2 mila e soltanto
in italia per la conformazione
geografica ne abbiamo 960 specie
io oggi sono qui per questo sono qui per
parlarvi di un mondo ronzante di vita e
di biodiversità straordinario le
chiamano api selvatiche
ap solitarie api native
sono loro le vere vittime di questa
scomparsa loro perché sono dimenticate
sconosciute hanno caratteristiche
straordinarie diverse tra loro
innanzitutto vi anticipo non fanno il
miele è forse per questo che nessuno
la più piccola e grande 4 mm la più
grande 3 cm alcune sono mono letti che
significa che si nutrono solo
esclusivamente di un tipo di polline di
un tipo di fiore
va da sé che se viene a scomparire quel
fiore addio un'intera specie di api
alcune le chiamano proprio solitarie
perché vivono in solitudine e altre
fanno diciamo dei nidi con piccoli
esemplari e ne scoprirete che non tutte
costruiscono nel nido di cera come siamo
abituati a pensare alcuni nidi ficano
sotto terra
altre invece cercano dei nidi
artificiali come nei buchi nei muri
piuttosto che steli d'erba o cannucce di
bambù
vogliamo parlare dei bombi spesso
volgarmente chiamate calabroni il bombo
fa parte di questa meravigliosa famiglia
pensate che è stato introdotto negli
anni 80 nelle serre di pomodori proprio
perché si è scoperto essere l'unico
insetto in grado di fare la base polli
nation vuol dire che con le zampette fa
vibrare le antenne dei fiori e a 400
hearts attenzione e fa cadere il polline
che favorisce l'impollinazione prima di
loro i pomodori venivano scossi da delle
macchine per far cadere il polline
oppure venivano dosati con ormoni per
aumentare la produzione una solo colonia
di bombi può servire una serra grande
quanto 3mila metri quadri
insomma ve l'ho già anticipato anche gli
insetti impollinatori come le api
selvatiche sono ottimi impollinatori
anche più bravi a volte delle api da
miele maggiore allegagione maggiore
produzione meno frutti deformi e poi
volano dall'alba al tramonto e non si
curano del maltempo volano anche quando
più vicina
questi insetti purtroppo come potete
immaginare e vi ho già detto stanno
scomparendo la colpa è nostra
di quelli diciamo col parabrezza pulita
per intenderci il cambiamento climatico
l'assenza delle stagionalità e quindi le
fioriture che sono completamente
scomparse che sono cambiate nel tempo
l'urbanizzazione e la cementificazione
quindi l'assenza di opportunità di
nidificazione l'agricoltura intensiva
queste monoculture non c'è prenotazione
dei campi non ci sono più fioriture
bordure insomma vogliamo parlare dei
pesticidi
uno studio dell'università di bologna ha
scoperto che basta un pasto venuto a
contatto con un pesticida per uccidere
una intera linea di successione di
un'ape solitaria questo è facile da
capire perché nel mondo delle api da
miele la reggina depone 2 mila uova al
giorno
le api solitarie di uova nei depongono
cinque dieci al massimo
ma in un anno
noi possiamo fare la differenza io sono
convinto che possiamo fare veramente
tanto dobbiamo cominciare dalle nostre
abitudini alimentari
scegliamo prodotti non trattati
impariamo a leggere le etichette usciamo
dalle dinamiche del supermercato
innanzitutto scegliamo frutta e verdura
di stagione perché il cambiamento
climatico
la colpa e l'inquinamento e se noi
continuiamo a pretendere prodotti dall
altra parte del mondo e anche questo è
inquinamento e poi informiamoci ci sono
produttori veramente intorno a noi a
pochi chilometri che fanno lotta
integrata producono degli ottimi
prodotti di tipo biologico se abbiamo un
prato non facciamolo ogni domenica c'è
il prato inglese non è bello
guardatelo con gli occhi di un ape non
c'è neanche un fiore le bordure i fiori
spontanei l'erbacce questo
questo è il paradiso delle api questa è
la loro vita la loro alimentazione e poi
aiutiamole a trovare un rifugio di un
riparo un luogo di nidificazione
possiamo farlo anche con i bambini è un
gioco molto bello possiamo utilizzare
delle cannucce di bambù o delle cannucce
di cartone possiamo costruire questi
nidi ospitare delle api sull'italia che
forse non l'ho detto ma non sono per
niente aggressive molto e non hanno
neanche il pungiglione e vi assicuro che
è meraviglioso vedere sfarfallare in
primavera e in estate
insomma abbiamo fatto un viaggio
veramente rapido mi rendo conto alla
scoperta delle delle api native
io spero veramente di tutto cuore di
essere riuscito a trasmettervi che il
rispetto per questi insetti non è
soltanto la loro salvezza ma è anche la
nostra
grazie
[Musica]